well hello gamespot viewers GameSpot
readers whatever you do on GameSpot hi
it's Kevin Van over here and I'm I'm
seated although you can't see us with
Bradford tell from star doc and Brad
you're here to show us Galactic
Civilizations three a project that's
been in the making for for some time now
yeah well yeah it's been four years
we've been working on it to build a a
brand new engine we wanted to make a
game a sandbox game that had incredible
scope gigantic galaxies hundreds of
players all kinds of craziness so that
players could really build their own
some interstellar civilization so glad
cessations it's a space strategy game
set in our 23rd century and the premises
is that humans have developed
faster-than-light Drive and the question
the game asks is what kind of
civilization are we going to be because
the galaxy is not empty it is full of
other civilizations so when you first
start the game the game does let you
play of one of nine major civilization
so you have the terran alliance who are
based on earth that's who we're going to
play as and then you have everyone from
the dren jin who are your when i made
them up back in the 80s they're you know
green space apes so they have come a
long way they well donates to look like
a lazy but yeah and and on each one has
their own interesting things thing in
glances agents 3 is that if you've ever
played a civilization game you have a
these kinds of games heavy tech tree
well include civilizations every single
one of these races has their own
technology treaty so it's a very very
different experience for each one but
you can also go and create your own
civilization from scratch and this is
where like sandbox is sandbox games tend
to lend themselves towards modding
there's a really good city building game
that recently came out that I'm not
going to pitch here but it's a great
game but yes but it really shows on how
a sandbox game can be really fun
especially hand to the modding community
so in this game you can go in and
literally create everything you might
want about a civilization how productive
they are are they
Andy what do they look like what their
ships look like given their own ships so
later
so I wants to make the Klingons they
could make the Klingons and download the
ships from some on mining and have that
now ship it's interesting you show me
that ship design and the first thing I
think of is there's a little bit of
enterprise a little bit of Star Trek in
that design how how conscious are you
when you're when you're creating whether
it be ships or races sort of the the
iconic images that we that we have
regarding what ships should look like
regarding what aliens should look like
is that something you're conscious about
when we create these oh yeah we try to
make sure what ours are pretty original
but there tends to be I of T's like I
have teased the team about hey look is
stimuli and Falcon Enterprise type I you
know and so it is it's an interesting
thing because now all the ships that you
see in a game they're not like models
this is not a someone did not make this
with 3d studio max or whatever the game
actually comes with a ship designer so
you can make any type of ship someone
loud I posted on Twitter the other day
so I made Voltron literally volt right
so you can have all try no you can
actually export them in 3d print them to
if you really like your ship oh Lord and
then when you're done with it your race
well what happens if you want to play
against it well you can Asian determine
how the AI is going to use this so this
is like the underlying user interface
for how the artificial intelligence
system will make it so that you can
literally make someone play a certain
way so every salute because it's not
very fun if you're playing against ten
or if let's say you have 50
civilizations and they basically play
the same and they talk to saying that's
against ignoring so I'll go ahead and
pick the humans and I'll do the default
settings a medium galaxy I can set all
kinds of different options a new player
can literally just come here and press
Start and be in the game which is nice
in the old days when we were in the
older Galactic Civilizations we kind of
let our inner grog guard take over and
say oh no no you're not getting into the
game until you have set up 50 different
things and you can but you don't you can
you know they have these nice defaults
and I could come in here and set my
opponents and I got these are and set
their intelligence levels for each
and then pop I'm going generating and
you can even limit victories if you want
to make sure that the whole game is
based on war you can do that if you want
you can and a game has a lot of
different victory conditions so like
this is a background of Terran Alliance
but like the way the ways to win the
game are you can do of course conquer
everyone but you can also win through
culture if you actually build up enough
culture to conquer the guy you can
actually see your cultural influence
that's what this this little line around
here is my area of cultural influence
it's not a political boundary right so
if you take over enough of the galaxy
with your culture you can win the game
if you have that set we get a
technological victory working in a
sanctioned victory which is these
special resources and you can also get a
political alliance that's where your
ally with everyone so at the beginning
of the game since I'm playing it to
humans it's the year twenty to forty two
and so the first it's kind of you can
tell when I made first came out the
first Gauss it back in a many many years
ago because the idea was well at the end
of of astray certain strategy game you
worship your Connie ship goes off in a
space nervous right and I always want to
know what and that's and here's your
common space all right yes what's beyond
all right so to speak and so I would sit
off my Connie ship and go off into the
galaxy so I'm going to send off so you
literally have here's the Oort cloud
there's earth or Saturn Mars Mars you
can actually colonize this if you want
and which we do in one of our other
games off world training company you do
colonize Mars which is nice but we're
going to send off the Kona ship over
here and this ship here is your survey
ship there's lots of interstellar
anomaly that I can go and acquire
basically it's your goodie Hut finding
ship sure but it can up there's all
kinds of cool stuff there and I you also
get a scout so you can go off and start
sending him off so this is only a small
galaxy through there's not very much
that's the entire map and it doesn't
seem very big until you're in doing you
realize oh my gosh there's a lot to do I
do have one question though about
victory conditions since we were on that
subject before and it strikes me that
you know there's certainly a resurgence
of for X Games recently a lot of things
showing up on steam and in other places
but what's interesting is that a lot of
these even though they're called for X
Games a lot of them seem to be very
military focused and a lot of the other
stuff seems sort of like well it's just
there because we have to have it there
but it's very meaningless or it's it
doesn't really make sense based on we
haven't built it in as well as we could
have in in gal Civ 3 what do you know
how you know do you think you balanced
that stuff pretty well like is it is it
fun to do diplomacy is it actually a
pretty deep system or you know obviously
you're gonna tell me very good so it's a
but I'm kind of curious where you think
that it's not that in my demo um that I
brought I had a hard time because I
actually personally played the game as a
diplomat and the way that works not sure
you when we do this a game is that you
have this technology tree let me show
you our tech trees this is something
that you most most of time for X Games
will have a very what we call a very
narrow tree so that at the end of the
game everyone will have the same tanks
and that makes it a lot easier for the
AI i but in this game it's there are so
this is just one of your four tech trees
that you get playing as two humans and
you have colonization which is making
your plants nicer engineering which is
as name implies about building up your
infrastructure warfare is only one of
the trees so these are different areas
of the game that you can actually try to
improve yourself as a civilization where
it gets really interesting is that on
governance I can go and build up
diplomatic points and that what that
means is that the other players it's not
a matter of oh you're weak we're going
to kill you and now that's what usually
happens in these games and these Forex
games what often happens is that they'll
say well we have all these way to win by
the fact is if you're all a big military
everyone's gonna gang up and kill you
well and the way we solve that and we
touch down a little bit in the last
conversations but this time we've had a
lot of time to think about it is that
the technologies can actually give you
what amounts to is diplomatic sway as
savvy so to speak so they may think
you're really weak and they'll tell you
when you meet the other aliens that's
you're really weak and what I'll do is
I'll go down when we're going to say get
because and that one we've already met a
bunch of civilizations I've gotten
Orr's and you can kind of see how the
Turks but so it's just in terms of the
beginning of the game so I'm on earth is
that one of the big changes is that
where you place things in the game
matters on the planets beyond Civ
historically every plan in the galaxy
had a planet rating on a scale from one
would say one to twenty the more the
higher the rating the better of the
planet and that determined how many
things you could build well it's still
that way except now I'll if what you
play we have adjacency bonuses so like
my colony capital if I build it gives me
bonuses to anything I build adjacent to
it so I have to make some tough choices
early on and this is what for anyone
who's reviewing the game one of the
things that's also different is that we
actually start out every player with a
bunch of cash 5,000 credits it's
basically whatever you want to call it
but 5,000 and the idea is that you can
go and decide what your early strategy
is right away without having to wait a
bunch of turns of getting going so I can
literally come over here go to my
shipyard choose to build a colony ship
and just buy it now I'm using up my cash
in doing that but allows me to whatever
my strategy is maybe it's building a
planets or claiming galactic resources
that's what this is here is one that and
I think that's an artifact over there
there's a lot of ways as you get
familiar with the game to to execute on
a particular strategy so um one of the
things that's also different to and this
is in every one of these parks games it
seems like late in the game it bogs down
I just get I'm endlessly having it build
orders to things right right and we've
we think we've nailed that here with by
splitting off the shipbuilding part of
the game from the planet stuff so in
other words the thing that builds ships
is now a shipyard it's actually on the
map and planets can feed into it so you
don't it's not a one-to-one ratio so
it's not like weather in a typical Forex
you have a colony or a city and every
city as building a unit or whatever and
by a late-game I have 30 cities so I'm
cause
right right well I could have if I
wanted to I won't recommend it because
talk about putting all your eggs in one
basket I could have one shipyard for my
entire empire and then everything
everything your cities are doing just
feeds right into that shipyard and
everything's popping out of there
right exactly it'll make the ships goal
build faster there's a the further away
they are from the shipyard the more of a
distance penalty you pay right in terms
of corruption or graft or whatever but
the point is is that you have a lot more
control over how much stuff is is
happening so that's a particular game
begins is it's pretty humble well you're
going off there's these stars you're
with their different plants around them
let me go ahead and do a turn here so
yeah colony ship I'm gonna go ahead and
I'm just gonna find Mars and whenever I
when I first colonize a planet the game
does kind of walk you through trying to
give you a little bit of significance of
it's kind of a big deal colonizing a
planet is sure non-trivial sort of like
invading a planet in this game you can't
invade a planet just by taking ACE a a
fighter and attacking a planet and going
into orbit and you've won you have to
actually build this transport with
troops and send it over there so a lot
of detail by the way going into the for
example the planet surface maps
themselves obviously with earth you have
a great model to work from as you move
away from Earth there's a lot more
imagination that goes into that stuff
because we don't know what those planets
necessarily look like across their
surfaces but was that you know was there
a lot of like when things like that are
that are sort of known like Mars was
there a lot of effort into modeling it
more or less like as we know what Mars
looks like yeah there's not supposed to
be an accurate version of Mars and we
actually had a version of this where we
put water on it in order to get an idea
where you could build on Mars oh right
as you get further the plants are
actually randomly generated so when you
see a particular plant you should never
see it again right so there we wanted
the main point is that we want every
single game to feel like a new game so
what I do is I'm gonna load up a game
where we've gone a ways we're at war and
that sort of thing alright so here we
are now we're a hundred and seventy
turns into the future and I saw my
shipyard
but now I've designed some ship
and I'm at war so let's go ahead and
look at the very we have conquest
victory influence victory I'm nowhere
near doing anything there I'm not very
influential in this particular game
technology victory ascension victory and
diplomatic well so much for diplomacy
this time anyway yeah unfortunately
while going and trying to get good pew
pew does mean I'm less popular exactly
now this is a bigger map and that's just
giving ideas my lord this is and this is
not by any means close to the biggest
map in the game I just didn't want to
get a bigger map because I well you
can't see on camera is I'm ringing this
off on MacBook four year old MacBook Pro
but the galaxy is big and I so I have
even so 170 some turns I haven't even
gotten to most of the galaxy yet so my
particular issues are with my local
galaxy cluster right so let's see when I
go to govern I currently have things a
little bit more on tech as I found out
as I was negotiating with our
civilizations I was a little bit behind
these are my various plant colonies and
what they're building this is one of my
favorite things I use this a lot this is
like the anti micromanagement thing I've
always thought that every Forex scheme
should have this and that is I can
literally say every place everyone who's
building this should I build this or
every everyone who's currently sending
it something here should they go here
instead right so in a one click I can
instantly tell a whole bunches of ships
or whatever to go somewhere else without
having to go click they could be click
like one at a time one at a time
yeah yeah so right now I have everyone
who's going to unassigned should go to
and I have some rally points I can send
them off to well that's fantastic like
it I mean you see that sometimes in
real-time strategy games where it's like
um you know units that aren't doing
anything you but you always have to have
units doing something in an RTS and this
it's really easy in a turn-based game to
get bogged down by like lots of units
and having to go to each one and figure
out what they're doing that's a that's a
really great little thing
thanks yeah and another thing is some we
were talk about this earlier so you saw
a big the galaxy is right that size
galaxy would be one of those
that's a neat checkbox well who wants to
play that big of a galaxy would be so
micromanagement intensively game or at
least it would be for me I mean I love
large games and then until you get them
in like every turn you're just doing 50
thousands but I only have four shipyards
so I have all these planets over here
these are my but I only got four
shipyards they all feed into them so I
can go a little over here I can edit my
sponsors and decide how many of the
who's feeding what very easily these are
the ships I'm currently building I
designed most of these myself just
during the game the game is really easy
design your own ships I can literally go
in and I'll do a new ship and I can
decide at this point my technology has
allowed me to get to be able to build
really big ships so I come over here and
start adding ship part it's literally
like Legos and people with talent I've
done some mom as and not me have done
some pretty amazing stuff with the stuff
as you so think of this is like it Legos
a little red dots right I like your
sticky things and Legos and then I can
come in here and change the size here
and I mean you could like spend a lot of
time doing it so you can even export
your designs to be 3d printed if you're
really into what you've just made so
with something like this and and and I
imagine I already know the answer to
this but but I'm sort of curious I mean
when you do stuff like this
is is the cosmetic customization all
separate from from functionality like
when I'm adding some large space in
there is it potential that's like oh
like I'm also adding like engine power
or I'm also taking away space that crews
would need to live in or things like not
on the cosmetic part of it that comes
over to the equip are you okay so when
I'm done with how I want my ship to look
physically I come in here and I and
that's where I would put in like warp
drive so everything that has actual
function uses space on the ship it uses
a pass and you only can have so much the
bigger the ship the more stuff you can
jam sure
jam onto it so so for example I can come
in now how I choose to make hyperdrive
look on my ship is up to me so I can
come over here and I can choose where I
put it
does it matter it's so now I have to
hyper or whoop drive module is on here
and whoredom put some plasma pods so
I'll make this really state-of-the-art
and and you can and if you really want
if you're not into the ship design part
you can we the game will generate all we
generate ships for you if you just want
to build like a sip style game where I'm
just building whatever it might Technic
or I can just come in here and just
clickety click click you know just Auto
place them so have you I mean the game
has been in beta and people are already
playing it I'll try to be nice about it
but what what kind of things have people
made I mean do people generally either
we both know we both know what they
don't know we know there's an article
and my son's first thing they do with it
you know what the ship they made I think
we were shot even saying so I have no
doubt there will be a lot of phallic
looking ships so is that something that
actually concerns you guys or is it
something like well that's just the
nature of the thing and if people want
to make penis ships they're gonna make
penis ships yeah okay yeah I mean they
should be able to make whatever they
want most people though I mean based on
what people have submitted
we get a lot yours you know I'm doing
enterprises in Klingon ships and Star
Destroyers and transformers because you
can animate all this stuff too it's not
a static and all kinds of crazy stuff
and but like the main things you're
trying to get out of your your designs
are what type of weaponry you have what
kind of fences you have because you need
to look at what your opponent has are
they if they're if they're focusing on
on let's say missile based weapons we
refined rockets and you then maybe you
should be
and because technologically you're not
really capable of researching up all the
trees right if you're going up the
missile based weaponry technology tree
you're probably not gonna have time to
go in and do the phasers and right stuff
so
if they're doing that then you go well I
need a research tech for point defenses
or chaff and ECM and all that kind of
stuff to kind of share encounter that so
that's where a lobbyist decision-making
comes into play so I'll come in here and
you also have how what kind of range
because you don't have on them you can't
just make a ship and fly to your side of
the galaxy especially on a big map so
you have to put in life support system
so that your people don't you know
starve before they get to their
destination you will also have how fast
which is where the warp drive comes in
and there's also things to add more
hitpoints to the ship and but all these
things use space so when I get done here
I'll just call this the don't call it
the intrepid no let's see though I went
back when early in debate I'm a big
Babylon 5 fan I had all the I had made
all the earth Earth Alliance stuff in
there so and meanwhile over on so they
this so far in technology I have
actually gotten reasonably far in most
of the areas so like on colonization
I've got enough stuff here where I can
do better farming and planted so the
game really does emphasize when you're
colonizing planets of hey there might be
a pre-industrial Society here what are
you gonna do about them orders disease
right well if if we landed on the alien
planet I said if you read the book Guns
Germs and Steel no I haven't oh it's a
great great book but it kind of points
out you know if we were to go on our
planet even if we could breathe I like
that like they breathe okay we can
breathe everything's fine it's like yeah
you're probably going to die there's all
kinds of issues you run into and into
that because it like I said a game
supposed to be a sandbox right it's not
a let's go build a ship a bunch of ships
and kill the other guy I didn't in
Prometheus though they all just like
kind of turrets oh yeah oh yeah exactly
it's like no there's all kinds of
problems that they have to work through
there so then how big of ships you can't
just go and build star destroyers and
turn one in fact at the beginning the
game my first ships are called armed
shuttles
right now like if humans started going
to space we probably not even armed our
ships because everyone's happy and by
late you so you're first armed things
these arms shuttles sure and in
governance I've been trading with
different civilizations so let's take a
look at them so since the game can
support up to 128 opponents potentially
we had the mate we had to do some
interesting stuff with how we display
different races yeah we couldn't just go
and put a bunch of pictures on the
screen of their faces because when if
there's hundreds of them so this is me I
can literally go over and mouse over
everyone and see the inner ones are
people who like me and the further out
you get or the people who died and me
and you can see what things and eat
you'll notice that everyone and this was
price hopefully shows better up on
camera is that you can actually see why
they were people like you and that has a
lot to do with how their AI was set up
so some are peaceful like space Gandhi
probably doesn't care that militarily
weak if you had space Gandhi in there
whereas a drenching over here they went
as soon as they saw they could conquer
me they declared war on me so you do
have there's ways you can solve that
though by one you're giving the money
building up your diplomacy like in this
game I did put in some effort into not
as much as I should have but into my
diplomacy skill so you'll see I have
three pluses next to my diplomacy skill
that makes them like me I all it took us
me put investing time in the researching
diplomacy but you see there's a lot of
people are at war with each other in
this game one of the big changes in
black civilizations 3 is this concept of
ideology this is another way in which
like said no a lot of people do like to
go in and make big fleets and blow each
other up sure but we do want to really
send home the message that this is a
game about what kind of civilization do
you want to be and so when you let me
give an example
my first co-ownership we go to Proxima
Centauri we land there and it turns out
there is a pre-industrial Society there
what do you do about it and the game
will ask you questions like well we if
one option might be well excellent
slaves right that's that's an option
that another option would be
maybe we should you know we need this
space too we can put some in
reservations of course I would never
have come real life but that's an option
and and then or another one for like me
this was their world first we we will
use the unoccupied parts of the planet
each option has some pros and cons like
if you choose like to make them slaves
well you're gonna productivity bonus but
you are you gain a point in malevolence
if you choose a more pragmatic view of
let's well we'll put them in
reservations and that you don't take a
penalty per se but you're not exactly a
great guy either right and if you do
benevolence that which is the other one
where you actually take a productive
productivity hit you get a problem than
an appointment each of these gives you
some benefits and some negatives as you
go up and as you run into other
civilizations they haven't gone up these
trees too so it gives you something
either that you know if you're a
malevolent you know bastard out there
then maybe the other guys will go well
we were trading with you but you you
guys are monsters we need to take you
out or if you're pragmatic you know
there's some other people who are nice
or might not think you're not such a
great guy either but each of these as as
you get more and more points throughout
the course of the game you can go up
this this little grid and get more and
more powerful attributes for your
civilization now of course you're your
current civilizations fairly warlike
well I actually went up to and I started
out for most of the game until I came
through here to because I have to show
it'll be a pretty boring game if I
didn't show our demo I should say if I
didn't show some pew-pew right so for
most of the game I was playing as a
trading benevolent guy so I'm actually
pretty far up the benevolent tree in
fact you can if we go here I can go to
earth to report and my my overall
ideology is benevolent I'm my race is
productive because I'm the one invented
FTL drives everyone's stole from me I
have my ships go a little faster or
organized when every civilization like
the thaelin here who I declared war on
even though I
shouldn't have because they're gonna
destroy me but that won't happen until
after this demo actually it might happen
I'd like it to happen during the demo
yeah I think I made some mistake well
one of the things I'm ship is I want to
show too is that the ship design matters
in terms also how you what kind of class
you make your ship I can make my ship a
support ship or a capital ship and I
purposely made mine like really badly I
made bad choices on my ship design which
I'm going to pay for so these are the
guys that were like they're pragmatic
and these are the things they like or
don't like me for but they don't like me
a lot because I attacked them for know
resettle do it yes so like over here
that's fine I have this battle ready to
go there I've put together these fleets
I have not actually seen how this will
end my lure is playing this this more
yet Starbucks so this could go either
way so this is a fleet I've put together
of my ships I have the Vanguard which is
my new state of the art I just designed
this it's I'm very proud of it it's the
Vanguard has the latest in plasma
weaponry
it's got good defenses it's huge
unfortunately that if I come over here
on the actually be easier if I show it
here what kind of 4x doesn't have grass
if I look over on the technology side
I'm up against these guys
so there's there this is their
technology they're way ahead of me so
like on paper they're they're pretty
good so I'm gonna go I think I think I'm
gonna win though because I I've set up
the demo so you know I'm not here I get
a little bit of cheat I don't know
though because their ships are so much
better but now I can actually the point
of the battle viewer is that you can
actually go in and I'm going to go in
here and it turn this to free and I can
go and look at every ship in here and
see all right how are they doing is it
range one of my weapon other so he's got
20 phaser attack so all his ships are
really good and he's getting first shot
on my guys this is my star hawk which is
my state-of-the-art fighter type ship
oops wait where's the rest of my fleet
okay way way back there this is where I
was talking about the bad decisions
remain is that when you can classify
your ships as a capital ship which means
they're the capital ship they hang back
right and and I I can also I have some
guys in escorts and then I was not
ordered then these guys are interceptors
so they're gonna they're just running in
the battle and are gonna get massacred
so this is one of those things where if
you the gamehole ottoman will give you a
suggestion well what you should do with
your ships I ignored that advice and
made something really bad to show off
how your decisions do matter
so here the mistake is is that these
guys ran up in the battle and now
everyone's going to concentrate on to my
bank on the Vanguard there's there's no
one left to distract them right exactly
so that's the problem here it's like I'm
probably going to die even though I have
this great ship because I was so foolish
in the way I used them I think I really
that was really a bummer oh man so this
is the case of I may have had on paper a
pretty powerful fleet but in practice
oh well that's right I have this guy
here he's ran away yeah you didn't later
make it I've got a couple of their ships
when it comes to how to the choices that
you make especially if you have a
victory condition in mind is there any
benefit to mixing stuff up or is it best
to stick to very specific ways of
handling things from the beginning or
you know can I be like sort of a maybe a
little bit of a jack-of-all-trades is
that gonna get me anywhere yeah the
answer that is it depends on how on how
much you've played the game when I first
started uh during design I had this I
had dreams of I had big dreams of I
would have a plan and I would execute on
that plan right I would lead me to
victory this game I'm gonna be a
technological master and I'm gonna get
that the problem is is that all my best
plans go to ruin as soon as they come
into contact with opponents
because like because first of all it
Earl
in this case space geography can make or
break everything like I know that you
can't really tell let me do on the
galaxy map here if I turn off this other
stuff here the ships and I just see
stars if I were to zoom out I just show
the galaxy so this is the entire map is
that what I want to do and what I can do
can depend heavily on geography so like
in this game and I know it's like I'm
looking at a tiny little corner of the
map here but I started out in this
cluster now maybe I could if I start out
in this isolated cluster up here maybe I
could have gone for a different a
different technology
like a technology victory or sanction
victory because I would be literally
isolated by a sea of stars I could build
Starbase defense outposts and and I did
that here you can't really tell because
it's like so when you've been playing
the game a long time you know where
everything is because you've been
playing it but I have built a series of
star bases around my borders that wreak
havoc on those who try to come in so if
you if I had a big sea of stars between
me and the enemy I could do that I could
do one right so in other words it's a
strategy game where you have to I have
to pay attention to what's going on
around you and other things other than
just this is my plan and I have to stick
to it
exactly yeah I mean if I start out with
someone like the Altair Ian's who are
really nice guys and well because I'm
gonna I'm benevolent they're benevolent
we're gonna get along great they're my
neighbors I have different store options
than if I had started out next to
basically the space Mongols here the
drew good old dragon Empire who
literally want to eat us in fact
alarming them out of their dialogue
whoops I'm at war with them let's find
out let's talk to I'm not war to your
when I go and I negotiate with these
guys what they want and and what I can
give them is heavily dependent on how
I've played the game what their goals
are so that you know maybe they'll give
me stuff maybe they won't depending on
what their what their personal
objectives are you I kind of when I look
at him I kind of guess I kind of feel
like I understand what his objectives
are gonna be for some reason he's not
subtle
yeah or don't like us and and one of the
things is that every player and isn't
from the modding point of view you can
go in and make it so that all these guys
say very different things under infinite
numbers of conditions I mean I would say
if there's this and this and this right
in the XML then they in this condition
this condition they'll say this to you
and it's really fine a little bit you
can spend a lot of time even if your job
is working out something else this is a
Terran Alliance offshoot they're like
the Confederacy good old R engine
these guys are I want to do a lot of
business he's out of the alt Aryans
they're the ones who like us oh yeah
these are ones how about if we end this
war let's you must be joking well how
about how about if I give them a bunch
of stuff ah now they're okay that sounds
nice yeah so now I'm not at work and I
only got away with that because the
thaelin are our pacifists right so when
I declared war on them for the demo I
kind of knew I'm aware to extricate
myself from my stupidity so that's
essentially the the basics of the game
every game is different and it's like I
said that this map isn't even close to
the largest sprite you can play on small
maps you can trade make your ship own
ships just trade them with other people
online there same thing with other
civilizations you want to make it's it's
that's pretty fun how was a typical game
I guess to close things out I'm kind of
curious I was a typical game gonna I
mean I can I imagine looking at maybe
some of the largest galaxies that you
know this is a thing that depending on
how I play this could take me weeks this
could take me months to really to really
see a conclusion as it were but is it
possible to get to the point where where
there's sort of a stalemate you know or
do you is it do you have it pasted in
such a way where it's always gonna sort
of lead to a conclusion rather than me
getting getting to the end of tech trees
and getting sort of mired in constant
struggles to do to either win or you
lose not as a tech tree okay as a
practical matter there's too many texts
that by a time you're like halfway done
the game someone's gonna have won the
game another thing is that this game AI
is pretty aggressive the players will
aggressively surrender that is if they
know there is no chance they will
surrender someone right so they're not
it's it's not a case where all god I
have to go and conquer every last little
this guy has no chance but he has four
planets on the other side of galaxy it's
like no he'll go and say I only have 5%
of population I have no military might
everyone's mad at me I'm just doing
everything to this
player right and on a small tiny map you
can finish that game in less than an
hour I mean we they're the galaxy's
agency has multiplayer in it so we have
these arena maps with only it's really
interesting too because you have these
arena maps where there's only like five
planets and the whole galaxy you're
fighting for them and it's really small
like well what do you do then what do
you do those opening moves at how you
spend that 5,000 credits at the
beginning really that's why the early
part of the game is so important right
well Brad in terms of housekeeping there
are always the usual questions I'm gonna
ask to finish things up with so in a
world where when is it finished means is
is a different question now than it was
10 years ago but in terms of your your
1.0 here is official release when are we
what are we looking at
well 1.0 is gonna go out on May 14th
that's really fast I know we're just
about done boy well we're about four or
five days from releasing a release
candidate for it I know in the old days
this build that were releasing on early
next week would be the one that would be
saying the manufacturing but thanks to
the miracle of digital distribution we
can I mean we would get to have
essentially an extra month of polish but
I am in terms of game being done I mean
really I hope that this games never done
I mean I've got the team and I were the
engine of this is built on it's been
designed so we can expand on for years
and years to come and I mean I would be
support I don't want to spoil things but
there's so much stuff that we can we can
do with this sure to make it just much
more interesting and sophisticated as
time goes on
well Gul Civ to thrived on on expansions
that came out afterwards is that sort of
the model you're looking at or are you
or is this just gonna be like just a
flowing river at this point or are you
gonna be planning on larger modules that
that that go on top later on well we're
gonna do both will have derbies there
will be DLC I know the art team is
chomping at the bit at so a lot of
people get really really into this ship
design stuff and so when you when you do
that I mean I and that's a sword they
make sense of deal see because people
who aren't into the ship design you
don't want them having to pay
right we're stuff that they won't
personally use so you know DLC that lets
them build more interesting stuff here
they will bring in some of our star
control stuff into here who knows Brad
thanks so much for coming by wow I can't
believe it so soon I had no idea it was
that quick yeah - suddenly upon me in in
the in the blink of an eye but thanks
for stopping by thanks for showing us
Galactic Civilizations 3 and you know
you can't drop something about star
control - or star control and and you
know just leave it there so hopefully
you'll come back sometime soon so we can
talk more about all of you guys are
doing but thanks for coming by and
looking forward to playing the full game
you
you